messieurs messieurs faire langue d'un
guilbaud nantel bonjour merci d'être
avec nous bonjour vendredi il y avait
des centaines de milliers de gens qui
étaient dans les rues de montréal y en a
eu aussi un peu partout à travers le
monde qui ont marché pour le climat qui
ont demandé à la classe politique d'agir
et qui ont un peu qui manque un peu de
confiance envers la classe politique
vous leur dites moi j'ai commencé avec
vous moi j'ai redit il faut pas qu'ils
perdent espoir
le geste qui ont opposé vendredi dernier
c'était exceptionnel ou de 500000
personnes d'après les chiffres donc il
faut pas qu'ils perdent espoir mais il
faut vraiment travailler plus et
continue à pousser auprès des
gouvernements
il ya beaucoup de travail à faire mais
on dirait quand il faut toujours qu'on
attende conçoit la dernière minute pour
qu'on passe à l'action
il ya des gestes à faire maintenant
concrètement et faisant rouler le plus
vite possible c'est ça le signal qu'ils
envoient mais se connecte en fait je
peux recevoir le message de la marche de
vendredi comme un message d'espoir de
notre jeunesse
il faut construire un environnement il
faut mettre en place des mesures
immédiatement et je pense que c'est le
message qu'on doit recevoir nous les
politiciens et politiciennes pour agir
maintenant
c'est une préoccupation et on l'a eue
nous l'ont témoigné avec la présence de
plusieurs milliers ici dans les rues
marianne jogging mais d'abord très très
fier papa de son fils de 16 ans qui a
convaincu la direction d'école de fermer
pour que tout le monde puisse aller
marcher j'ai milité en environnement
pendant 25 ans j'ai organisé certaines
de ces manifestations l'eau dont celle
de 2012 le voir comme ça
cinq cent mille personnes c'est un rêve
qui se réalise et je suis d'accord ça
vous met de la pression de pression
constructive à mon avis sur la classe
politique pour qu'on fasse plus pour
qu'on fasse mieux est encore plus vite
c'est noté mais faire faire faire plus
faire mieux c'est travailler ensemble
tout le monde va sont non partisane
relativement à sa fille ses choix je
pense que ces gens allaient guider dans
les rues et on a entendu des promesses
électorales de tous les participants des
confrontations de chiffres ce qui veux
c'est voir une vraie différence et
monsieur hulot
lorsque le ministre français a
démissionné le biais dit la lutte à la
crise climatique fasse faire de façon
non partisane alors j'espère que c'est
ça que mes collègues voudraient enfin
jacques roche sur ce que ce que veut ni
dire travailler ensemble travailler
ensemble de façon non partisane
on est en pleine campagne électorale
vous avez pas là
de parler le même langage convient tant
par les climats d'environnement comment
au fait je commence avec vous monsieur
regarder comment on fait pour travailler
ensemble parce que comment on fait pour
en arriver à un consensus parmi les
partis posé on fait quelque chose on va
dans cette direction là enfin monsieur
thibault ce qui est important c'est
d'avoir un plan d'avoir une vision est
de pouvoir poser des gestes concrets
maintenant
suite à ça il faut construire avec les
politiciens politicienne qui seront élus
le 21 octobre un aimant il ya une offre
une fête une offre quand même nous en
une heure on a passé d'un éclair le plan
est clair notre plan était déposée en
juin dernier le parti conservateur a
déposé avec notre chef andrew scheer en
juin dernier un plan très clair et très
complet j'invite les gens à l'île conçu
par milliers des gens qu'ils avaient
deux boîtes noires vont pas suffisamment
loin et kiiki de l'eau et avec les gens
qui seront en place nous on va
travailler dans l'intérêt de
l'environnement
il faut inviter la population à poser
des gestes concrets c'est eux qui ont le
pouvoir guilbon deux gibbons vous
défendez vous défendre le bilan votre
gouvernement là dessus vous dit quoi et
ça vous met d'abord que les analystes
indépendants qui ont regardé le plan du
parti conservateur estime que 1 eelv oct
et cher il de il ne permettra pas de
réduire mais au contraire d'augmenter la
pollution sur quatre partis représentés
ici vous en avez 3 qui estime qu'il faut
mettre un prix sur la pollution que la
pollution ne peut pas être gratuite
qu'on doit faire plus d'investissement
dans les transports collectifs plus
d'investissements dans les tri fication
dans les nouvelles technologies
moi je pense qu'on est prêt il ya des
pays dans le monde où il ya plus de
débat sur est-ce qu'on doit agir mais il
ya des discussions des débats d'idées
sur comment on le fait et je pense qu'on
est près de cent au canada mais on n'y
était pas encore tout à fait enfin en
fait mesures il bouge oui j'aimerais
vous répondre là dessus nous avons un
plat nous avons des solutions qui ne
sont peut-être pas les mêmes que celles
du parti libéral et dieu sait que ce qui
était fait des quatre dernières années
ne pas fonctionner et tous les experts
l'ont confirmé en fait vous avez acheté
ce que je me suis laissé moi c'est l'un
fait le seul de la production des
revenus
suspens permettez moi de vous interromps
je vais compléter ma réponse je veux
simplement vous dire que le seul moment
au canada où une baisse des gaz à effet
de serre c'est sous un gouvernement
conservateur sur la crise économique des
deux avances à loos n'exclut en andorre
rapidement je peux me permettre ce qu'on
a ici devant nous c'est plus parfaite
exemple les libéraux qui pensent avoir
la science infuse que tout est beau tout
ce qu'ils font c'est en belgique
non mais je vais pas vous mais votre
parti ça c'est sûr monsieur donné c'est
la même chose son parti évidemment jour
au niveau de non mais vous vous êtes le
plus que écologistes déjà du parti
conservateur mais certainement on
conviendra que vous n'avez jamais vous
n'êtes pas intéressé dans ce show
carbone qui de toute évidence sur le
baudet de la taxe carbone est
certainement la chose de plus efficace
dans le monde c'est pour ça que j'ai
demandé à tout le monde en décembre 2008
de travailler tout le monde ensemble il
tristement le gouvernement libéral aux
potes daigné répondre à ça on pas daigné
dire c'est la responsabilité du
gouvernement de rassembler tout le monde
autour de la table lorsque je vais
entendre monsieur fernand rapidement
bien sûr qu'on va passer à la pause mais
je vais vous entendre de monsieur fermé
oui
donc il ya des très bonnes idées au
niveau de plusieurs partis politiques au
canada c'est de travailler ensemble pour
vraiment les chercher les maires de
chaque idée de faire avancer la cause
moi je ne suis plus capable d'entendre
parler faisant comme quoi de
l'environnement coûte cher c'est pas
vrai ce rapport là rapporte
l'environnement mais moi je vais refuser
ce couplet odza yak 40 6 % des québécois
leurs préoccupations et l'économie
ok donc et par exemple le pays-haut
vient de sortir des chiffres qu'une taxe
de carbone représente des coûts de 42
dollars et d'ici 25 ans travaillent 60
quelques dollars lettre le coup en
dommages environnementaux en dommages
donc il faut travailler maintenant afin
d'éviter ces couleurs faut pas oublier
une chose ou si je vous suis aucunement
la pollution atmosphérique 36 milliards
de dollars en soins de santé
cardiovasculaire c'est l'institut
international sur le développement
durable qui ont affirmé ces chiffres-là
au canada uniquement divergences de
point de vue
j'aimerais revenir et je vais commencer
avec vous monsieur guilbeault va
s'avérer agitée l'heure assez fortement
et monsieur gaudin et vous vous entendez
pas sur la proche à prendre vous et vos
parties et ça vient alimenter le cynisme
de gens qui étaient dans la rue vendredi
sauvier alimenter le discours de
gettysburg qui a dit à l'onu lundi
dernier je ne fais pas confiance à la
classe politique
comment on fait pour passer par deux
chevaux pour régler ce problème mais je
pense qu'il faut travailler plus fort il
faut montrer qu'on est capable de faire
avancer les choses qu'on est capable de
faire changer les choses et mon message
à mes enfants à la jeunesse depuis plus
de 25 ans c'est pas vrai que les choses
ne changent pas le québec a commencé à
réduire ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre l'ontario la colombie-britannique
le canada nos émissions entre 2014 et
2017 la pollution diminue est passé il
faut il faut faire plus mais alors je
pense qu'il faut faire comprendre par
juste à nos jeunes mais à l'ensemble de
la population que les choses ont
commencé à changer mais qu' évidemment
il reste beaucoup de travail à faire il
faut pas perdre espoir il faut continuer
à faire pression c'est cette pression là
et elle est saine pour des gens comme
nous parce que ça nous permet à prayssas
d'arriver dans nos parlements et il faut
aller plus vite
moi je salue ces gens là ces centaines
de milliers de personnes qui étaient
dans la rue nous en avons besoin
puis on va être là pour vous oui
monsieur gaudin je les entends mais je
veux aussi vous alimentez parce que vous
parliez tout à l'heure de l'importance
de faire les deux protéger
l'environnement croissance économique
vous alimenter le discours de jean comme
madame tandberg qui dit exactement c'est
la semaine dernière il faut arrêter de
penser que la croissance économique
s'est c'est la panacée qu'il faut aller
dans cette direction
en fait monsieur thibault je vais
répondre au niveau du plan
environnemental que nous on a déposé
trois mots très simples sensibiliser le
consommateur c'est nous les gens dans la
consommation qui avons le pouvoir de
changer les jours et deuxièmement
l'innovation invité les entreprises à
innover et troisièmement arrêtons de
voir rien que le canada c'est un point 6
% des émissions de grande émission
portefeuille au canada par contre
il ya un consensus de la communauté
scientifique qui dit que si on ne met
pas un prix sur quelque chose comme la
pollution
il n'ya pas d'incitatif de la banque
mondiale mais je vous entends déjà juste
ce qu il faut bien comprendre que la
taxe sur le carbone que le parti au
pouvoir présentement mis en place il ne
fonctionne pas et le vérificateur
général du canada la commissaire à la
suite de résultats et y avait il ya
vingt ans il y avait une urgence et au
parlement a remis en juin dernier on
nous demandait de d'affirmer que cet
argent
oui c'est très con oui mais monsieur qui
debout oui c'est urgent
oui c'est urgent mais pendant ce temps
le gouvernement libéral pendant les
quatre dernières années s'avoue question
fait de conquérir le jour alors je veux
monsieur nanterre monsieur fernand merci
beaucoup parce que ça c'est vraiment
c'est la classique des deux vieux partis
c'est pour ça qu'on était en crise
médiatique les conservateurs se foutait
de la crise médiatique et les libéraux
en fait on ne rien faire pendant quatre
ans mais c'est la même chose pour la
crise climatique s'est brisée mais le
parallèle qu'elle veut faire la crise
climatique les gros sont attendus sion
pas intéressé pendant dix ans les
libéraux étaient trop chercheurs pour
faire de quoi pendant quatre ans et
viraux terminé leur mandat
en allant chercher une image
merveilleuse qui vous monsieur
guilbeault qui essaient les moins
aimables wings cette matrice et les
moins payés c'est moins pire avec les
libéraux et les conservateurs ça de ben
oui vous avez vous avez dit que le
pipeline abbas était proche pas mais on
a fait bien d'aujourd'hui ne s'était pas
senti millions
je sais jouer en temps mais j'en avais
envie c'est d'aller chercher les sous
qui dort dans les paradis fiscaux parce
qu'il va falloir investir énormément
d'argent pour la lutte aux changements
climatiques
il faut encore aller chercher aussi
taxer les grosses compagnies comme un
potier microsoft qui ne payent pas
d'impôt au canada qui nuit aux
entreprises aux petites entreprises qui
veut se lancer dans les mêmes
technologies
on va aller chercher ces argents là on
voit les investir pour les changements
climatiques est tellement de choses afin
qu'on peut faire replanter des centaines
de milliers d'arbres ont annoncé
qu'entre l'antenne de milliers encore
aucune cohérence dans le plan
environnemental grand sens que chez
madame mais ça fait 30 ans qu'ils
attaquent simon écologique ça fait huit
ans que je suis payé tout le monde en
fait aux compagnies pétrolières c'est
pas normal que ces grilles compagnie low
reçoivent les trois et quatre milliards
de dollars par année un jury monsieur
guilbeault la subvention les subventions
aux compagnies pétrolières monsieur
monsieur rideau monsieur trudeau avait
dit on va l'éliminer de la premier
mandat sera présentée qu'à brief
actuellement le gouvernement a acheté un
oléoduc
effectivement qu'est ce que vous
répondez mais d'abord les subventions
aux combustibles fossiles
on n'a pas fini de faire le travail mais
ça a commencé elles ont commencé à
diminuer les subventions il y en a moins
en moins d'argent qu'ils vont pétrolière
d'une part le pipeline écoutez moi je
lis mais il y en a des
environnementalistes qui sont fâchés
avec de renault m dos parce que il je
les comprends je suis pas d'accord avec
cette décision là mais si on ne regarde
que l'arbre on voit plus la forêt et moi
ce que j'ai c'est de regarder si la
forêt 50/50 plus de 50 mesures notamment
notamment sur les changements
climatiques nebbou on a rendement t on
en avait 1 % d'aires protégées pour pour
les océans comme lorsque nous avons plus
pouvoir
on va être à 20 en 2020 70 milliards de
dollars d'investissements
écoutez et regardez ces 50 milliards
c'est une pour votre partout grâce à ces
investissements qui nous restait dans
l'environnement au parti libéral du
canada et reste très peu de temps mais
c'est fernand mais je n'en prendrais
bien savoir les chiffres ici au niveau
de l'ailé de combien ça va rapporter on
n'a aucun chef actuellement on ne sait
pas combien temps que va durer non plus
20 30 40 ans on le sait pas du jour au
lendemain que le voilier avec les mines
de diamants au québec à mâcon a investi
énormément d'argent qu'on a tout perdu
donc le lait au duc est exposé on
exposait d'investir les profits dans les
changements climatiques
mais on voit même pas de chiffres au
bout de la ligne non plus ce nom tel
monsieur guilbeault moi ce que j'espère
c'est que malgré votre passage côté du
gouvernement libéral j'espère que si
vous êtes réélu j'espère que vous ferez
partie des gens qui vont considérer
l'option de madame mais qui est de créer
un cabinet de guerre à la crise
climatique qui impliquerait des gens de
tous les partis ça se travaille à ce que
c'est possible de trouver une façon de
faire travailler tout le monde ensemble
moi en tout cas ça fait six mois que
j'essaie de requise rapidement je pense
que c'est tout à fait possible et et
plusieurs le font déjà mais on a tout
avantage à travailler ensemble nous
serons plus forts
on n'a pas le choix je pense parce que
sinon on aux enfants et nos
petits-enfants auront demain de sagement
voyons voir si on peut le mettre en
pratique maintenant messieurs merci
infiniment d'avoir participé à
l'émission